muchas gracias buenas noches a todos ya
todas
bueno yo voy a comentar algo más bien
compartirles algo que tiene que ver con
un interés personal y de mi
investigación que más que ser académico
me da una enorme satisfacción y como
bueno ya lo decía alejandra si tiene que
ver con los pueblos originarios de este
país pero voy a empezar con un poco de
historia para que podamos ubicarnos no
va a ser tan tan largo el contexto de
los voy a meter
pero si tiene que ver con el período de
la conquista recordemos que méxico era
el méxico prehispánico antes de que
llegaran los españoles y en 1521
aparecen los españoles se consolida la
conquista y empieza un largo periodo de
casi 300 años que se llama virreinato
durante ese periodo sucedieron
demasiadas cosas se transformaron las
prácticas y todas las tradiciones de la
gente que vivían en este país que ahora
llamamos méxico había más de 260 lenguas
han desaparecido tantas en el transcurso
de estos años que ahora se hablan 60
entonces bueno de estas transformaciones
quiero referirme a la palabra tradición
podemos escucharla en distintos
contextos todo el tiempo podemos incluso
decir hablar de lo típico o de lo
folclórico yo me refiero a la palabra
tradición que tiene que ver con aquello
que se hereda de una generación a otra
es un conocimiento que tiene que ver con
una manera de pensar una tecnología se
hereda y se continúa a lo largo de
muchas generaciones se consolida por lo
tanto es mucho más fuerte que decir nada
más algo típico o algo folclórico y con
esto me refiero a los pueblos
originarios y a sus prácticas
de este encuentro con los españoles y
con los mexicanos antiguos podemos
pensar que se trata de un golpe cultural
muy fuerte porque la conquista no
solamente fue militar fue religiosa
ideológica y de este resultado derivaron
otras tantas costumbres y resulta en una
amarga miento que genera sus propios
productos y el cambio en las
mentalidades que también podemos llamar
imaginarios pasando muchos muchos años y
llegando al momento actual digamos a la
historia más reciente de estos pueblos
originarios y estoy pensando en el siglo
pasado y este siglo 21
el siglo 20 y el 21 han sido
determinantes en mayores
transformaciones estos 300 años que duró
el virreinato y ahora el siglo 20 y el
21 estamos frente a cambios
absolutamente vertiginosos porque porque
estamos enfrentando todo lo que implica
la globalización que todos sabemos de
qué se trata la globalización es una
manera de conectarnos todos en el mundo
y de todavía propiciar muchos más
cambios de mentalidad pero de manera más
acelerada de qué forma impacta esta
globalización a los pueblos bueno en que
impactan sus tradiciones en su forma de
vivir en su cosmovisión y que es la
cosmovisión es una forma particular de
estar o de pertenecer o de entender el
universo cada quien tiene una
cosmovisión diferente y estos pueblos
además hablan su propia lengua
construyen bueno elaboran su propia
vestimenta y muchas otras cosas además
de esta presión de incorporarse a una
sociedad globalizada porque la cultura
cambia es algo vivo y no se van a quedar
ahí estáticos guardados en el tiempo
además hay aspectos que los han
vulnerado considerablemente
cuáles pueden ser estos aspectos hemos
oído hablar en los últimos meses o quizá
en los últimos años alguien que haya
puesto un poco más de atención o que se
más relacionado con el tema tiene que
ver con una de estas producciones
importantes que se llaman los textiles
más allá de la cerámica o de que tengan
sus propias danzas o de que tengan
muchas otras formas de cosmovisión ellos
elaboraban sus textiles
de esta manera tradicional
hay algunos pueblos nosotros conocemos
algunos como los tener en la huasteca
algunos habrán visitado algunas de estas
comunidades indígenas les habrán
comprado cosas porque yo creo que nos
sentimos bastante atraídos por el
colorido de estos pueblos y eso es algo
que además exportamos al mundo entero
nos reconocen y tenemos fama de tener
una gran diversidad cultural entonces a
que están expuestos estos que hacen sus
propios textiles su ropa o a lo mejor ya
no se la ponen pero la elaboran para
venderla están sujetos al plagio
patrimonial de manera reciente y de
manera muy acelerada en los últimos años
hubo un caso muy sonado que a lo mejor
ustedes recordarán de una diseñadora
francesa llamada isabel marant
la comunidad una comunidad de oaxaca una
comunidad mixe se organizó y le dijo a
su presidente municipal aquí está
sucediendo algo porque hay una
diseñadora del otro lado del mundo que
está usando en nuestras figuras y
nuestras blusas para para su moda para
venderla y no nos consultó y no lo
platicamos nunca con ella de qué se
trata la comunidad se organiza le envía
una carta a ella y le dicen bueno señora
cómo de qué se trata este asunto no hubo
una respuesta inmediata por parte de
ella no escalo el problema pero bueno
este es uno de tantos ejemplos otro
ejemplo es este que ustedes conocerán
estos diseños se elaboran en un pueblo
en el estado de hidalgo y se llaman
tenango de doria qué pasa con estos
tenango de doria
los han usado firmas importantes a nivel
internacional y puedo decir los nombres
por ahí se ve la etiqueta mango los han
usado sara y recientemente louis vuitton
y no sé qué otras firmas pero cada vez
es más frecuente el que se reproduzca de
manera ilegal este tipo de iconografías
y por qué porque se reproducen porque no
existe un marco legal que proteja los
diseños colectivos de un pueblo entonces
están desamparados ante la ley están
desamparados también ante la sociedad
porque nosotros como sociedad muchas
veces no sabemos de qué se está tratando
este asunto de los plagios y además
vean este otro ejemplo
otro de los casos muy recientes fue el
de la famosa firma carolina herrera que
también utilizó estos diseños de los
tenango de doria y además de reproducir
el tapete de saltillo y otras cosas de
otros pueblos latinoamericanos en el en
esta ocasión que fue más o menos
reciente hace unos meses si hubo una
respuesta institucional desde la
secretaría de cultura a nivel federal se
emitió una carta preguntándole a la
señora carolina herrera si en algún
momento se había acercado a este pueblo
para preguntarle si le autorizaba la
reproducción de su iconografía y bueno
por supuesto que no hubo respuesta
tampoco otra de las preguntas que se le
hicieron a esta señora fue señora en
algún momento usted pacto con ellos
cuánto les va a corresponder
económicamente de lo que usted gane con
su colección 2020
la respuesta fue de su director de modas
la respuesta fue lo que estamos haciendo
es un homenaje a estos pueblos pero el
homenaje pues quedó ahí no no se ha
cancelado tampoco la venta de
de esta colección 2020 no sabemos en qué
momento saldrá pero al menos hubo una
iniciativa entonces es a partir de eso
que en este año apenas en el 2019 en el
mes de febrero la comisión nacional de
derechos humanos emite una emite una
propuesta una y una sugerencia me fue la
palabra exacta y le dice a él para
enviarla a todos los ejecutivos del país
a nivel bueno a nivel estatal y a nivel
local y les dice es necesario de poner
atención en este tipo de patrimonio y
protegerlo del plagio
los dueños y los hacedores de este tipo
de patrimonio son los únicos que pueden
decidir qué se hace con sus diseños pero
eso no es más que una recomendación
seguimos fuera del marco legal
bueno observando entonces este es otro
otro ejemplo que sucedió también con
otra comunidad de oaxaca y así hay
muchísimos más entonces bueno lo que
quiero a lo que quiero llegar con esto
es que nosotros como mexicanos debemos
considerar en todo momento que tenemos
muchas formas de patrimonio como lo
pueden ser todas las variables o toda la
variedad de lenguas que se habla en este
país este tipo de productos todo esto es
patrimonio cultural inmaterial que está
perfectamente tipificado por la onu y
por la unesco muy bien y entonces
nosotros como mexicanos con esta gran
diversidad cultural que tenemos en
nuestro país que hacemos con esto
yo creo que todos en algún momento hemos
regateado
cuando vamos a comprar algunos de estos
productos ya sea en un mercado o que
estemos turisteando en alguno de estos
estados maravillosos donde producen los
textiles o cualquier otra artesanía
regateamos pero si vamos a summers no
regateamos imposible verdad o en zara
podríamos regatear sería buena idea pero
no creo que resulte
entonces quiero terminar mi presentación
con tres propuestas y una sería pedirles
a todos sumarnos a decir no al regateo
reconozcamos y valoremos lo que tiene
este país de valioso estas culturas
ancestrales que nos están ofreciendo un
conocimiento de muchos siglos atrás
incluso en algunos casos algunos algún
mil y más años y estamos regateando ese
conocimiento la segunda propuesta es hay
que tener mucho cuidado con los
productos chinos nos están dando gato
por liebre qué quiere decir nos están
vendiendo productos mexicanos productos
chinos como si fueran mexicanos y no no
hay tal y estamos inundados de mercancía
china
de chatarra que no beneficia a estos
pueblos la tercera propuesta sería
fijarnos si estamos comprando le a un
intermediario porque los intermediarios
muchas veces compran a partir del
regateo y le suben el precio dos o tres
o no sé cuántas veces más entonces si se
trata de un intermediario al que le
vamos a comprar
podríamos al menos interesarnos en saber
si pertenece a alguna red de mercado
justo
y con esto les los dejo pongan atención
a los diseños y el patrimonio mexicano
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]